new poll finds little support for the
Republican health care bill the poll out
yesterday shows only 21% of American
voters approve of the GOP plan passed by
the house that is no surprise to some
Republicans Republican lawmakers have
faced angry constituents and town halls
around the country during the Health
recess and Iowa congressman got an
earful from voters in his district Dean
Reynolds says the shock
saw he saw the sharp questioning and
he's now in Des Moines Iowa gained good
morning good morning well we attended a
town hall hosted by congressman rod Blum
and while it got loud at times Blum got
off relatively easily compared to some
of his Republican colleagues answered
yes or no
in North Dakota a scuffle broke out at
this town hall when one man approached
congressman Kevin Cramer but it didn't
end there while most town halls are
rarely physical during this week's House
recess almost all have been passionate
[Applause]
[Music]
from Michigan
to Virginia voters are expressing their
anger over the GOP plan to repeal and
replace Obamacare on Wednesday
representative Tom McArthur hosted a
heated Town Hall in New Jersey that
lasted a marathon five hours and didn't
simmer down folks you get to ask the
questions and I get to answer that so
answer them in Marshalltown Iowa angst
over the health care plan shared the
stage with another issue will you
support an independent investigation
into Trump and his campaigns purported
ties to Russia not the current time the
firing of former FBI head James Comey
fired up this crowd at Iowa congressman
rod Blum's town hall
if Trump was guilty of something would
you fire the FBI director cuz that's a
pretty that'd be a pretty dumb move I
mean I get it you hate the president I
get it my mom represents a district that
President Obama won twice but went to
mr. Trump last fall the few Trump
supporters at the town hall here say
Comey and Russia did not bother them the
investigation is done by the guys in the
field all right one guy even if the head
guy doesn't make any difference to
whether or not that investigation goes
forward or not now adding to the anxiety
the Republicans may be feeling is new
polling out now which suggests a clear
majority of Americans find fault with
the president's decision to fire the
head of the FBI
Gail Dean thank you